if you had a bet in the next
presidential election based on one trait
what would you pick gloss hair color
family history Illuminati membership
size of their super PAC maybe size of
their hands well professor Greg armory
has the answer this in his paper on how
physical trades affect our choices and
leaders Murray found that from 1789 to
2012 she would bet on the taller
candidate he would have been right 58%
of the sign that alone should probably
be the end of the video 58% is an insane
advantage if you consider that height
has nothing to do with actual knowledge
of how to run a country for foreign
policy so with that we should be able to
exit out of this video sad that our
elections have been so extensively
hijacked by biological prejudice but
unfortunately it doesn't stop there
because our data set isn't a complete
picture yet nobody decided their vote
based on height before the television
because they couldn't say voted based
only on what they heard from the radio
and news only since 1960 how we had
televised debates where the voters had
been able to clearly tell us was taller
so if we separate out these data sets
into before television and after
television we find two things first in
the elections before 1960 our
assumptions that they were unaffected by
height turns out to be true the odds of
the taller candidate winning drops to
51% as we would expect of people not
able to see their candidates before
voting to them secondly in our post
television data set our biological
prejudices are worse than we thought
from 1960 to 2016 the teller candidate
has won 67% of the times
also if one candidate is more than three
inches taller than the other their
chances of winning go up to 83% again
it's absolutely insane that height
matters this much to our election but
although this is a bit depressing it is
in line with what we know about
behavioral psychology there are many
theories on why we like taller leaders
some studies say height is an advantage
in size because it means you're punching
down which generates the force and makes
you a better fighter in a primitive
setting this is how you would elect the
leaders the strongest man would
eventually win other theories suggest
that we pick our leaders based on who we
physically look up to think of when
you're a child your peers are always
those who are generally around your
height and the adult the people who know
stuff are the ones that are taller and
bigger it's possible that we never get
rid of that bias when we grow up and see
people who are taller as being authority
figures but no matter the explanation
one thing is clear we want a leader who
control
center of attention and dominate a room
physically we perceive them to be better
suited for the job regardless of whether
that is actually true or not we always
look to the tall guy so if you want to
know who the next president will be when
the election cycle rolls around again it
might be worth muting the debate and
just checking who is looking up to
[Music]
Oh